between 1966 and 1973 one of the
greatest shows ever made for television
ran and its first run and then in
syndication almost constantly throughout
the 70s and I grew up absorbing this
show Mission Impossible I can't tell you
that I understood the complex politics
of the plots but I understood deeply
that the agents cool under pressure of
the impossible mission force team
allowed them to complete their tasks
time and time again and I coveted their
cool and when my father threw out a
small zero briefcase somewhere around
1974 I knew exactly what I wanted to do
with it and I had already learned at
that point that in addition to Lego a
cardboard box and a roll of masking tape
are one of the most powerful tools for
creation ever invented so I took a
cardboard box
I cut out a sheet of it and I put it in
the bottom of that zero case then I cut
out a hole and I used a cell acetate
because my father was an animator and I
drew a radarscreen
I lit it with a giant six volt lantern
battery which was what I was allowed to
buy at the hardware store and powered it
with two flash light bulbs that I
literally taped the wires to I then put
toggle switches in there and a speaker
grille and I labeled one of the toggle
switches in an amazing bit of precedence
detonate and I spent hours in my yard
pretending to get signals from other
members of the impossible mission force
team and responding to them and
correctly hitting detonate at the time
it was supposed to be hit fast forward
to 1981 I am 14 years old and 1981 was
an amazing time if you loved stories and
especially if you love movies to be 14
years old the list of important and
amazing films that completely shaped me
is too long to go into here suffice to
say escape from New York Divac Sharky's
machine Raiders of the Lost Ark Dragon
Slayer all came out that year but
there's this one movie that that hit me
that I want to talk about and John
Boorman had been trying to make a
version of Lord of the Rings since 1968
and when financing didn't come through
on that because his vision of it was too
expensive he
reduced this vision a little bit and
made an amazing sword & Sworcery film
called Excalibur his retelling of the
Arthurian Grail legend and this movie
was a hard-r it was bloody and there was
guts and crows eating eyeballs out of
skeletons and there was sex and I
managed to convince my dad to take me to
this movie twice and in addition to all
that other stuff the thing that really
captured me about the film was the armor
the and the armor you can't miss it in
the movie every male character in
Excalibur wears their armor everywhere
to dinner to the bed to sex they're
constantly wearing armor and the whole
story is told in armor in the beginning
the armors black in its knobby and when
King Arthur builds the round table and
Camelot the armor is all sparkling and I
didn't know that I was seeing Nicole
Williamson and a young Helen Mirren
showing everybody else had act I didn't
realize that I was watching Liam Neeson
Patrick Stewart and Gabriel burns first
movie what I knew was I saw this armor
and it represented some type of
transformation to me and I wanted a
piece of it I came home and we had those
lattice slats of wood protecting the
underside of our house from raccoons and
I pulled one out of a spot that probably
wouldn't be missed and I went down to my
dad's a shop and I planed it into a
sword shape and I spray-painted it with
silver and when it wasn't silver enough
I figured out that you could buy a
luminize tape at the plumbing store and
I made aluminized aluminized this sword
blade and I found a little glass bead
and I put it in the bottom of the hilt
and in the movie Nicole Williams since
performance he's this beautiful
modulated voice and I could hear his
voice in my head as I picked it off the
workbench behold the sword of power and
I felt the power
I really felt this this object that I
had made had this power to me it had a
weight and it had a swing and a swish
that I deeply craved so for Halloween
that year this was the summer of 1981
for Halloween and October I made myself
a suit of armor again out of cardboard I
even made a white horse that I wore with
spenders and I wrote it around school I
lost the Halloween contest to a Mickey
Mouse with big puffy hands then my
father told me that there was an armored
room at the Metropolitan Museum of Art
and I made him take me and if you've
never been to the armor room at the
Metropolitan Museum of Art it is an
absolute wonder there are four mounted
Horseman horses wearing their own armor
I didn't even know such a thing existed
and this is I took a sketchbook and I
made sketches of the armor and slowly
built a notebook of reference because I
wanted to make my own suit of armor I
still do but I asked my dad for I'm
trying to figure out the exact timeline
but I believe somewhere in there I went
into therapy because I was a lonely kid
and the therapist told my parents that I
was too close to my mom and not close
enough to my dad shocking so my dad
started to spend more time with me and
one of the things I guess that he did as
a project was he went to the hardware
store and came back with a roll of
roofing aluminum and some pop rivets on
a pop rivet gun and he taught me how to
take planar forms like sheet aluminum
and bend it and crimp it and tie it so
that you could make compound curves and
slowly over several weeks we made me an
aluminium suit of armor
we used buckles from rotting luggage we
found in the basement and we made
everything the crease the tassets the
knee cups the elbow cops the placard the
helmet I needed an excuse to wear this
which is of course Halloween again
because every year at Halloween everyone
came in costume and they went around and
took pictures of everyone now my first
suit of armor is in fact visible in my
1981 high school yearbook because I
stayed around all day and the
photographer found me and took a picture
the second suit of armor the aluminum
suit there are no pictures of it and I'm
really sad about this but it's because I
didn't last past third period in the
armor I went to math class and I was
standing in the back in my full suit of
armor because I couldn't sit down
and even from the back miss Salva
raucous my math teacher said are you
okay and I said yes I am
and then I slid down the wall and passed
out of heat exhaustion and I woke up in
the nurse's office and in a key moment
when life becomes an allegory for itself
I woke with a start and said where's my
armor my armor had been put on a shelf
in the art room along with all these
other things that I had built I was
incredibly prolific in the art room in
my high school by my junior year I had
made dozens and dozens and dozens of
really elaborate things many out of
cardboard but out of all sorts of
mixed-media and my armor went on the
shelf next to that and I trusted that it
was safe but that summer the principal
went in and in a fit of space-saving
zeal throughout that entire shelf of
stuff an act that so enraged me I
actually at sixteen consulted an
attorney about whether I could sue him I
couldn't but it so depressed me to lose
those objects but specifically the suit
of armor that I didn't build anything
else for another 18 months I went on to
fall in love deeply in love with film as
a storytelling medium and as a method of
transformation and eventually ended up
calling it a career I got my first job
in special effects in 1993 up here in
San Francisco I'd started off in the
theater industry and got hired by my
partner on Mythbusters Jamie Hyneman and
that led all the way to actually coming
up here to Lucasfilm in 1998 I got hired
on Star Wars Episode one and it was like
dying and going to heaven I was working
with people that I'd been reading about
since I was 11 years old when Star Wars
first came out and that was the second
job I ever knew that I wanted was to
work on Star Wars and here I was up in
Turner Boulevard and then eventually up
here at the main house at the ranch
working on Episode two and building
spaceships and models and one of the
first things I discovered working on
advanced and beautiful movies like I was
working on here worked on AI I did all
the destroyed buildings in New York
space cowboys I helped build the Space
Shuttle and did everything inside the
payload
Bay Terminator 3 sorry about that
second two Matrix films sorry about
those two but I learned as a model maker
that like every job in filmmaking my job
was to tell stories just as much as the
directors was that when you're gluing
what we call grebe Lee's to the side of
a spaceship you have to have an
understanding of why every grebe Lee is
there it doesn't have to be clear to
anyone else but that panel has to have
an internal logic and when it does it
feels right and there are different
logics to the Star Trek universe and the
Star Wars universe in Star Trek it's
totally okay to have three objects one
two three next to each other in Star
Wars you can never you have to have one
two and then there's a space and then
there's a third because in Star Wars
everything's being fixed all the time
every car is under construction so at
least one fender is spray painted primer
gray and the whole time I was working on
those movies and honing my skills and
even onto after 2002 I got hired to do
Mythbusters which I've been making for
the last 12 years I still kept on
building objects and things from
narratives that compelled me I spent a
year replicating Indiana Jones father's
Grail diary from the third Raiders film
maybe the only good thing in that movie
but every last newspaper clipping and
silver certificate and train ticket I
put in there I hand weathered every page
and because when you're doing something
like that it's only marginally harder to
make 12 than it is to make one I made 12
of them and I traded them to people for
other props that I wanted I hand machine
myself a Blade Runner gun and actually
it's out there in the lobby and that's
the third Blade Runner gun I made I made
one when I was 18 I made another one
when I was 26 and the last one I made
when I was doing Mythbusters and I could
afford to actually buy all the original
guns that the real Blade Runner gun is
made from and hand gunsmith every single
part and piece and nut and bolt to make
it exactly the weight that it should be
and I'll tell you I still pick it up
from time to time just to feel that
weight and that that transformation
I also spent 14 years making the zf1
from The Fifth Element out there not
fourteen straight years but looking at
screenshots building the entire thing in
3d then finding out that Steven Lane
from the prop store of London it
actually bought a real one and he gave
me access to it for a few hours to make
measurements and then make my own
totally accurate I had to throw out the
old one I've still got it but I wanted
that total accuracy now I keep on
looking for projects to dive my head
into and if you love stories like I love
stories and you love film than you love
Stanley Kubrick and there's a traveling
exhibition of his archives going around
the world right now and it was at LACMA
in LA for a bunch of months and if you
didn't get to see it there I exhort you
to head up to Toronto after November
where it's going to be for about six
months it's a remarkable exhibition
everything from his point five lenses
that he shot Barry Lyndon with his
director's chair his archives for
Napoleon costumes from Barry Lyndon
original drawings from AI that I
remember seeing it didn't realize they
were from the Kubrick archives but there
was this one thing oh I also you know
saw one of the spacesuits from 2001 but
I was already making one of those so I
didn't need any more reference of it but
there was a piece that really compelled
me and it was from dr. Strangelove maybe
my still my favorite of all Kubrick's
movies I'm always surprised every time I
see it how both upsetting and how
hilarious it is and yet how I leave it
feeling really really unpleasant about
humanity but it within that movie there
is this one object and it's it's out
there it's half complete and I don't
usually show things that are half
complete but it's within the spirit here
it's major Kong's survival pack that
comes to for somewhere around the
beginning of the third act of dr.
Strangelove so to refresh your memory
major Kong's plane has been shot
he can't go above 150 feet and amazingly
limping over the Russian countryside
this is what's allowing him to escape
the gun batteries that the Russians are
trying to use to shoot him down so he
doesn't deliver the a-bomb and caused
the doomsday device to kill the entire
planet and in this Kubrick skewers every
single facet of the military in this
film from the British man dragged to the
idiot
idiotic sergeant bat guano to Jack D
Ripper the only military man within the
film who show a quiet cabin quiet
competence are the pilot and his crew of
this Flying Fortress bomber led by Slim
Pickens and as they realized that they
might not deliver the bomb and they
might have to ditch and they might end
up in hostile territory he pulls out
this list and he starts to go through it
I'm going to read it to you
he says 145 caliber automatic two boxes
of ammunition for days concentrated
emergency rations one drug issue
containing antibiotics morphine vitamin
pills pep pills sleeping pills
tranquilizer pills one combination
russian phrase book and bible one
hundred dollars in rubles one hundred
dollars in gold nine packs of chewing
gum
one issue prophylactics three lipsticks
three pairs nylon stocking shoot fell
could have himself good weekend in Las
Vegas with this stuff the line was
actually supposed to be Dallas but they
were editing the movie when President
Kennedy got shot and they changed the
line to Las Vegas now I got home from
having taken pictures of Kong survival
pack Wow five minutes I'm going to go
over time taking pictures of Kong
survival pack and I started researching
it and the things I discovered when I
started researching it if you were ill
if you were issued condoms during the
Cold War in the mid 60s which is when
this movie was supposed to take place
you were issued trojan fins and they
made special ones for the military it
took me six months to figure out how
gold would have been packaged as they
gave gold to Gary Powers when he was
shot down and they packaged it in a
really clever way now CIA operatives use
what's called a bot necklace that has
different gram weights of beads and they
can pull them off and trade them for
various amounts but back then they
usually had Krugerrands sovereigns gold
watches and gold rings and they were
cast inside a block of foam rubber so
that you couldn't steal them if you did
it was clear you had cut into the pack
and there was a whole protocol for
dissolving that pack I discovered that
no survival pack in history has ever had
nylon stockings or lipsticks as part of
it but of course Kubrick's telling a
whole nother story the subtext of the
Kong survival packet is telling you a
whole nother story about the film
because of the purpose with which
chooses those items now I'm not only
making one I'm making a bunch of them
and I'm not even sure why except I know
that I don't want to sell them I'm not
interested in getting money for these I
want to trade them because trading is a
way in which actually a whole nother
story gets told about the object but why
like I actually grapple with this
question I have a cave in the mission in
San Francisco and it is overwhelmingly
packed with objects that I absolutely
love and there's thousands and thousands
of them and the why of it is something
that I grappled with for a long time
until I started going to comic-con
now myth busters got invited to
comic-con about seven years ago and I'd
always wanted to go and I'd always known
that it was deeply about costume and so
am I clearly so every year at comic-con
I put an elaborate costume together the
first year I was Hellboy after that I
was a stormtrooper I was a ring Wraith
this year I was in the alien space suit
and a Mercury spacesuit that's out there
in the lobby for you to see but about
four years ago I put together a costume
that didn't take me months to build and
it didn't cost thousands of dollars it
took two weeks and about a hundred and
fifty bucks and it remains my favorite
costume I've ever built
it's from Hayao Miyazaki's film spirited
away and spirited away is on one level
it's a story about a little girl coming
to understand her own power but it's
also about her rescue of a sad spirit
named no face or Kuniyoshi and no face
is this sort of amorphous blob with a
with a white face and he's very sad and
he's very humble and I built this I
slumped vacuform plastic in a hole to
make the oval and then I painted it and
then because in spirited away you can
actually see through no face most of the
time and you can see that there's sort
of a figure within the figure so behind
the head I've AK you formed a clear
plastic head that I wore on a kayak
helmet strapped tightly to my jaw which
hurts like hell and I can't see anything
out of this costume all I can see
through the mouth is people's shoes but
I wore it out on the floor and walking
in oh also he has these long black arms
and I wondered how am I going to get
long black arms on eyebrows I live in
San Francisco I went to the drag queen
store I said you have long black
comes up to my arm and they said shiny
or matte so I walked out onto the floor
and I was no face and I could see people
freaking out and if you've seen the
movie and if you ever see a
seven-foot-tall no face costume it is a
bit arresting I remember the first time
I saw one and people were coming up and
asking for pictures and I would bow my
head and I would take a picture with
them and then I had in my gown a lap
pack full of gold chocolate coins
because this is one of the ways in the
film that no face draws people to him he
makes gold appear in his hands and he
lures people to him then he eats them he
eventually vomits them all back up later
in the movie but the gold is the way he
thinks that he has to make friends so I
had gold in my pack and when people
would take a picture and they'd be done
I would have one ready and I would make
it appear in a flourish and I would give
it to them and they really were freaking
out they love this right and I was like
oh this is great and I could see that
they ought aku the Japanese girls the
geek girls were really freaking out
about it oh my god they're taking
bunches of different pictures and then
after about 30 minutes somebody grabbed
my hand and they put a gold coin back in
it was an angry gesture and I wonder if
I gave chocolate to a kid who's like
charging to chocolate or something I
didn't know and it kept on taking
pictures and giving out the coins and
then it happened again and it happened a
third time before I realized what was
actually going on what was going on was
that in the film it's bad luck to take
gold from no face and the attendees at
Comic Con were giving me back my gold
because they wanted no part of no faces
bad luck and then I realized that we
were all participating in a theater that
that when I put on these costumes or I
make these objects they're all part and
parcel of the same activity I'm
injecting myself into a narrative that
has fed me and I'm attempting to build
it around myself so that I can put
myself inside of it I can feel deckert's
pistol I can hold on to the egg gun I
can look at borns bag and pretend it's
over my shoulder and that I'm a secret
agent
all of these things are real experiences
I have with those narratives and with
those objects but I used to think that
story was a one-way was a one-way
transmission from teller to listener and
what I realized in that moment of
theater at comic-con was that the story
not only changes a good story not only
changes the listener but it changes the
teller as well that the story evolves
every time it gets told and we've been
telling stories to each other since we
sat around campfires and taught
ourselves better and faster in easier
ways to kill large animals with
sharpened sticks that language came
about because of story and it might be
the story of a lonely 13 year old kid
trying to find his place in the world
and finding solace and narratives or it
might be a 47 year old man and his love
of telling stories but we are all part
of that process and something that
evolves like that a story is actually
something alive and it is evolving
alongside of us at least that's my story
and I'm sticking to it
thank you very much